pau ghazi khan n'a ni philosophe
conférencière franco-algérienne
islamologue bonjour merci d'être avec
nous nicole belloubet la ministre de la
justice admet son erreur ce matin et le
droit du de blasphème je cite je n'avais
pas à dire ça c'est sûr en rappel elle
avait dit l'insultent à la religion est
évidemment une atteinte à la liberté
d'expression
le débit de le délit de blasphème est
sur la table
le délit de blasphème je pense que
france il n'y a pas de délit de
blasphème la loi française ne reconnaît
pas le délit de blasphème et grâce
évidemment un bon philosophe des
lumières qui ont travaillé sur le sujet
parmi ces philosophe voltaire qui a pris
l'exemple du chevalier de la barre pour
expliquer justement et démontrer que
derrière le délit de blasphème
il y a eu se cachent de l'obscurantisme
donc il a appelé à la liberté
d'expression et en france la loi protège
les individus n'est et non la religion
ou dieu
donc il n'y a pas de délit de blasphème
dans la loi française par rapport à tout
ce qui s'est passé il y avait beaucoup
de réactions il ya notamment eu abdallah
zekri le délégué général du conseil
français du culte musulman le cfcm
il a déclaré que milla devait assumer
les conséquences de ce qui l a dit
'comment est-ce qu'il faut interpréter
ce qu'il a dit dans un pays où la
laïcité est de mise
ce que monsieur écrit adi il ne doit pas
être dit par un représentant de l'islam
de france ou de l'islam d'une manière
générale un car c'est un appel à la
violence et un appel qui considère que
dans les propos de millas il y à une
provocation et tant qu'il ya provocation
annulation la violence à son égard et
que risque justement de leurs écrits je
ne sais pas ce que la loi réserve dans
ce cas là mais c'est des propos qui
mettent en danger la vie
une personne qui aimait là évidemment
donc ce ne sont pas des propos comme je
viens de le dire que représentant de
l'islam doit tenir un représentant de
l'islam doit tenir un discours qui
permet aux musulmans de france et
musulmans d'une manière générale de
vivre dans la société française avec
avec harmonie avec dans un climat apaisé
et non un climat de violence et de
tensions et il faut qu'ils tiennent un
discours qui démontre aux musulmans qui
veulent être musulman qui sont attachés
à la religion qu une autre manière
d'être musulmans est possible
une manière qui est plus compatible avec
les lois de la république avec la
modernité avec l'humanisme et je donne
deux exemples le verser 125 della sera
de 16 la sonate des abeilles qui invite
au dialogue et à l'échangé et non à la
violence et le verser 105 de la sourate
5 lasserade de la table servie qui dit
clairement aux musulmans vous êtes
responsable de vos propres actes
et si l'autre est égaré celui qui était
garée ne voulut et points si vous vous
avez suivi où vous avez pris le bon
chemin
donc 2 verset que les musulmans peuvent
utiliser pour aller vers un islam
nouveau à nice l'âme du 21e siècle
malheureusement la majorité des
musulmans préfèrent d'autres versets qui
appellent à la violence
aujourd'hui il faut aller vers un islam
qui appelle plutôt aux discours et qui
respecte la liberté d'expression la
liberté individuelle de l'autre donc
justement vous allez parler de verser de
violences en tous les cas en parlant de
violence et mila
a reçu des menaces de mort et de viol
elle était scolarisée
est-ce que ça va pas un peu trop loin
finalement toute cette affaire
cette affaire de mila a pris des
proportions aussi grande car en réalité
site une affaire de la république
française et de la société française
d'une manière générale mis la main
dessus
mais la halle incarne une affaire de la
société justement et c'est la république
est menacée
ce sont les valeurs de la république les
lois de la république qui sont menacés
et c'est pour cela que cette affaire
après autant d'emplois elle et elle a
pris autant d'ampleur car ou dans la
société française aujourd'hui nous avons
des jeunes musulmans qui considèrent que
protéger la religion est plus importante
que respecter les lois de la république
il y à des jeunes musulmans aujourd'hui
en france ceux qui ont menacé mais là
évidemment qu'ils considèrent que sous
prétexte de protéger leur religion ils
ont le droit de se faire justice la main
et que risque justement ces personnes là
est ce que la justice va
justement se prononcer je suis pas
juriste je ne peux pas répondre à votre
question je peux tout simplement vous
dire que nous avons donc des éléments
qui nous permettent de déduire qu'il y à
une menace contre la république et c'est
pour cela que ça après des des
proportions aussi grande et je continue
mon propos donc nous avons aujourd'hui
en france des non musulmans qui
considèrent que mes amis là mérite ce
qui lui arrive donc des non musulmans
aussi français qui considèrent que
bafouer la loi de la liberté
d'expression est tout à fait normal le
quatrième point c'est que la majorité de
ces gens là qui ont menacé milla je
considère ou gym je suppose qu'ils se
sont des jeunes de son âge
donc nous avons aussi un problème c'est
que l'école française ne transmet plus
les valeurs de la république
les valeurs de la modernité les valeurs
de la de l'humanisme et c'est là que se
situe le problème
et enfin cette situation provoque autant
de malaise et de tension car elle révèle
une chose importante le degré de l'
influence du fondamentalisme islamique
au sein de la société française ces mots
de la fin merci
ghazi khan n'a ni d'avoir répondu à nos
questions vous et islamologue
philosophie conférencière franco
algérienne